if you go back to like 1965 1970
um in the social sciences and humanities
you can see it's about three to one left
to right
and it's now about 1213 or thereabouts
so it's gotten worse it's not the case
yes academia particularly social
sciences humanities has
has leaned left for a long time but it's
not lean left to the same extent it has
now
things have gotten much worse
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people and a brilliant
guest we have for you today he's
returning to the show for the third time
a professor of politics at birth by
college university of london eric
kaufman welcome back
delighted to be here you guys this is
great and i'm very impressed by the way
with how you guys are rising in the
world with this studio so that's very
kind of you to say
as i said to you before this is what
happens when you criticize blm in public
your life just gets better and better
but apart from the fact you've got no
friends but we don't talk about that
i i never had any friends in the first
class but eric listen it's great to have
you back we wanted to get you back
because you've just been involved with a
couple of reports one in particular
looking academic freedom something we've
talked about plenty in the past
so uh tell us what's going on what's the
situation how free are we
well i think it's important because
universities are where kind of
cancer culture and wokeness emanated
from so i think it's very important to
start there
and see what's been happening um so
really there have been three reports two
on the uk
and one now that i did on the u.s canada
and the uk which was much larger in
scope
it's worth mentioning that the sort of
2020 august
uk report on academic freedom was the
one which
five of our seven recommendations went
into the uk government's white paper
so we're very pleased with that take-up
of a lot of the ideas
and and i think it sort of gets to the
notion that part of the practical
aspect of trying to take on cancer
culture is forming these policy networks
think tanks academics government
where you can get some of these policies
enacted
but before i go into that detail i've
just put out a more recent report for
the center for the study of partisanship
and ideology which is a new think tank
based in
california very small but what's what
they're trying to do is get out
sort of unconventional social science
research into the policy space and and
broadly into the domain because so many
of these questions are not being asked
in universities because
you can't ask them or no one's
interested in them for ideological
reasons
so for example studying wokeness you
know that's not something that's going
to attract
a lot of funding
[Laughter]
so so what this report does is it it's
based on a lot of original research
eight surveys
uh taking the uk surveys that we did for
the um
the policy exchange 2020 report adding
on to that
surveys in canada and britain and some
surveys of post-graduates so phd
students
and what do we find well basically what
we what we find is we confirm a lot of
previous research which shows that
social science and humanities academias
is extremely left as you might imagine
so the numbers we were getting was were
about 14 to one
left to right uh in canada and the u.s
and about nine to one
in britain other studies using sort of
votary registration data which are more
of a complete sample find
something similar 12 roughly 12 13 to 1
in the top
100 say u.s institutions i also looked
at the top 40
canadian institutions so what you've got
now is more or less a monoculture
you have a very small number of
conservatives a small number of
centrists
the conservatives are more or less in
the closet for the most part
that atmosphere is one in which uh
essentially it's not a free idea space
where
all ideas are challenged equally good
ideas have an equal shot at getting into
journals or getting grant funding
what i wanted to do with the surveys is
to actually look at academics themselves
as well as graduate students and find
out not only their political beliefs but
also
their support for cancer culture because
we didn't really have any proper studies
on that
and then willingness to politically
discriminate and then number three
how much are political minorities i.e
conservatives to some extent centrist
but also gender critical feminists how
much are they uh
essentially feeling unfree because so
many so often you'll get this retort
from the academic establishment and
particularly the progressive left that
well it's a few no platforming incidents
which make the news these are blown out
of proportion there was only
you know 65 incidents it's only 0.01
percent of all academics that
encountered this and that's true
so i want to say that is actually true
if we just want to
focus on no platformings as the problem
it is kind of a small problem
but it's a symptom what we argue in the
report what i argue in the report is a
much
symptom of a much larger threat to
academic freedom which is chilling
effects
all right for every one person who gets
no platform they're 10 people who don't
allow themselves to be in our platform
because they don't speak up in the first
place
yeah but more than that i wanted to get
at the
everyday academic in their teaching are
they
do they feel free to raise issues in
their research
are they researching what they really
want to research and saying what they
really want to say
in conversation in public commentary
well
lo and behold the answer is no i mean if
you take conservative academics
in the u.s and canada uh who are in the
social sciences and humanities it's
about three-quarters who say
their department is a hostile climate
for their beliefs it's about
between six and seven out of ten who say
they self-censor
in their research and teaching um if you
look at trump supporting
academics there are a very small number
you know one out of ten would let that
slip to a colleague
whereas biden supporters it's about nine
out of ten right so you're you know
you're talking about
a major difference in who feels free to
speak and who feels free
within academia so it's really a problem
that's concentrated heavily on
political minorities which is why a lot
of academics who tend to be center-left
they don't see this because it's not
affecting what they do they can just do
their research do their teaching what's
the problem
it's like in china you know if you just
have a nice life you go to parties you
drink you do whatever
what's the problem here i don't feel
unfree it's only once you cross
the ideological regime that exists and
it's similar in a university
it's only when you cross a boundary uh
which is
it could be around hot button issues
race gender sexuality not having the
right
opinions so a kathleen stark for example
on gender critical feminism
boom all of a sudden you're in trouble
you're getting no platforms you're
getting called into disciplinary
tribunals
um but as long as you tow the line
you're fine and so something similar in
academia
the other thing is being a conservative
is it's not technically crossing
um one of these hot button issues but it
is more or less associated with being on
the wrong team and therefore
you also kind of endanger yourself if
you're identified as such and therefore
very much this small group of maybe
three to five percent of academia is
just the gender critical feminists the
conservatives
in the social sciences and humanities
that's who we're really feeling
this heat this loss of liberty so i kind
of concentrate a lot on them
but also it's not as if the the vast
rump of academia
is off the hook because they it's it's
they're complicit in this system
so it's not as though the trump
supporters and the conservatives and the
gender critical feminists are just being
paranoid
that actually everybody would love them
and be open to their ideas well
not really because if you look at i did
a
something called a a list experiment
which allows you to get at people's true
views
uh in a way that a direct question
doesn't and what i
found was essentially 4 out of 10
u.s social science humanities academics
would not hire a trump supporter
and 45 percent of canadian academics and
in britain it's about one in three who
wouldn't hire a known leave supporter so
you've got
pretty high political prejudice
operating if you think about
going up for promotion or trying to get
something in a journal
you know if you've got four referees and
well 40 and 40 of them are are going to
be
politically biased the chances are one
or two of those people
are going to be against you if they can
smell your politics
that means you're going to keep it
you're going to keep that politics in
the closet in your work
right so this is the dynamic that's
that's going on is
it's not so much fear i mean it is fear
of losing your job i want to
come to that cancel culture point in a
minute but the biggest problem is
political discrimination
um political discrimination is a huge
topic and which
is it seems to me not receiving anywhere
near the attention it needs to get
it is massive and it's not only academia
actually if you take people of
say you know whether left or right they
both discriminate
relatively equally inside and outside
academia
it's just much more acceptable for
people to say i don't like this person
because he's a tory or
he voted for corbyn or whatever and
that's going to influence my decision
that's actually not allowed in a hiring
decision or a firing decision but it
seems there seems to be a tolerance for
it
so anytime you get an institution that's
say 10 to 1 or 14 to 1
of one group say in the university's
case it might be left to right
all of a sudden you're in a climate
where there is massive political
discrimination because
in a situation where it was 50 50
everyone's equally prejudiced
the prejudice will cut both ways yeah
you might annoy one person but someone
else might favor you for your views
so it comes out a bit more in the wash
but once you get a situation that's
highly tilted
yeah that one person may be equally
prejudiced as these ten but ten to one
means the effect
hits the political minorities just that
much more and that's kind of what we're
seeing
in academia and what that then means is
you get
with political discrimination you get
two things one is self-censorship
and people concealing their views but
also you get
people being repelled from going down
the academic track and some of one of
the surveys i did which is which was on
graduate students showed that
conservative graduate students
particularly at the master's level knew
that academia was not a place that was
friendly to
their political ideas and that that was
significantly linked with
not wanting to pursue an academic career
so what you're now
into is a sort of self-fulfilling
feedback loop where
you've got a hostile climate for
conservative or gender critical beliefs
that keeps people with those beliefs
from coming into the profession which
keeps the
sort of impurities out and keeps it a
mono culture and so it's reproducing
itself
um and the the big question is is
whether that dynamic is going to migrate
to
other spheres like publishing like uh i
don't know motion pictures or whatever
uh which which may not be quite as
advanced as as you know they are maybe
they are i'm writing my first book at
the moment believe me they are
yeah yeah yeah so so that's that's the
issue is is and
and if you go back to like 1965 1970
uh in the social sciences and humanities
you can see it's about three to one left
to right and it's now about 12 13 or
thereabouts so
it's gotten worse it's not the case yes
academia particularly social sciences
humanities has
has leaned left for a long time but it's
not lean left to the same extent it has
now
things have gotten much worse and i
think part of the explanation is the
spiral
where you get you know a monoculture
which is then hostile which then deters
people and that just drives this cycle
more and more
um so yeah that's pretty much the
message of the of my report on on
uh academic freedom recently the there
weren't uh
specific policy recommendations in this
one the way they were
the the way they were in the in the
british one the british one had
a series of policy recommendations
which i would also largely endorse for
the u.s case it's just that
cspi didn't want to go into the policy
side of it and so i said fine
we won't do that because we had some
disagreements among some of the other
fellows and i thought okay we'll just
yeah we'll keep it out of this we'll
keep it empirical uh but i wrote up some
of the policy stuff for
city journal which is the manhattan
institute's uh
in-house organ and uh sort of laid out
some of my policy thoughts in that piece
which which largely kind of follow from
what's been done here in britain
um and and it also gets into a wider
conversation
maybe you should remind people what what
what they were yeah so
for for your viewers particularly not
from britain um in back in february the
government
uh basically committed to well in a
policy white paper they
set out some reforms um that were going
to be made
to um to to universities here now they
have this is still to
pass through and become law but it's
almost certainly
likely to go through it's just a
question of whether it goes through in
its present form or whether there are
some amendments that are made but
basically what this um legislation
does and policy guidance does almost all
of it is about
enforcing current law but it's about
doing it proactively right so
instead of for example your academic
freedom rights being violated because
the university says
what you're saying um it puts our
university in a bad light we've had some
complaints from students
aka kind of you know twitter mob um
we've had these complaints and therefore
we would like you to you know stop
writing what you're writing or whatever
or or we haul you in and we we punish
you in some way we take you off
uh take you from this position you're no
longer uh on this committee or you're no
longer able to
to teach that so there's a punishment
that's involved well
that is actually a violation of your
academic freedom even under current
law but the way the law is set up now is
you've got these different obligations
there the universities have an
obligation to ensure academic freedom
but then they've also got their
uh policy and work and study where you
can't be seen to be harassing anybody
and harassment is loosely subjectively
defined and then you've got our you know
our reputation of the university and and
that well we can't have that sort of
besmirched
that's all used in a way uh to trump
academic freedom so academic freedom
comes last and it's more or less thrown
under
the bus whenever there's a conflict what
this legislation would do was
essentially say
you can't do that academic freedom is
number one and all these other
considerations are two and three
and so if there's ever a situation where
you you say academic freedom is trump by
these other things
you are actually going to be told to
change that decision and you're going to
face fines
so there's a regime that involves a new
office um someone called the academic
freedom champion which sits on the
university's regulator called the ofs
here in in britain
uh and what they would have the power to
do is essentially investigate
universities and essentially tell them
to reverse decisions
issue fines and so on uh this is the
only way
and and i know there's a discussion
around this i have this discussion with
with others who say no no the market
will sort it out and
people will vote with their feet and
good ideas will drive out the bed and no
it's not
actually how it works in a system such
as the university system where
there is first of all it's government
funded secondly there are there are huge
network effects and legacy effects
uh you can't just set up new
universities left and right because
there are
tremendous advantages to being
established
so you have to work to reform the
existing sector which means you've got
to use
the power of government and that for
some libertarians is anathema
and i think if you go down the path of
being a libertarian on
on issues around wokeness whether it's
tech firms or universities or whatever
in my view you're being a useful idiot
for the woke
all you're doing is essentially taking
away the only lever we have
to try and roll back this stuff within
these institutions
um eric can i just stop you there just
for a second because we're using the
word
woke and this means different things to
different people
right because to some people they would
say well woke means just being socially
aware aware that you know
black people face racism trans people
you know they're exposed to
you know their own form of prejudice
what does wokeness actually mean how
would you define it
okay very good question one sentence
sacralization
of historically disadvantaged race
gender and sexual minorities that's the
one sentence definition of woke
so once you say that these categories
of people are sacred that means then
that
any kind of criticism of anything that
might help or
is in the name of helping these groups
right affirmative action could be won um
microaggressions could be in any any or
or even
the government's recent uh paper on
equalities and anti-racism
uh if you say structural racism or
institutional racism doesn't exist you
know any criticism
of something that is in the name of
these sacred groups becomes
in effect you are putting yourself in
the excommunicated box
so wokeness is really about
sacralization
of categories of people and that's the
bedrock behind it all
so that's the definition once you have
that definition and once you see
certain categories as being sacred and
holy
both in terms of their lived experience
in terms of their knowledge not equal
holier on the one hand higher on the one
hand lower because they need your
protection you're the parent
they're the child right so there's that
kind of dynamic in which
any kind of um criticism of any sort of
anything that's adjacent in any way uh
to the sacred
uh totems is a blasphemy and and that's
kind of what mcwhorter is talking about
in his
religion of anti-racism as well is
there's this very religious sacred
quality to this
discussion so when i talk about wokeness
it is
anything that sort of would elevate
these categories and any
ideas around these categories as beyond
reproach beyond criticism and and
any research which might be construed as
being
insensitive or in some way critical of
that to be essentially struck down um
so it prevents any kind of rational
discussion and i think we see this in
the in the recent uh
race commission report where you know
just saying look we've got to look at
what is the driver of
you know higher you know disparate
sentencing between black and white or
or disparate outcomes in in terms of
maternal mortality
we actually have to look at not just
racism you know there is a gap there but
we don't just jump to races and we
actually want to look at
well what are the other factors that
might be going on that
like not pleading guilty for example how
can we address
these other drivers of the gap that is
heretical because it
in it questions an explanation i.e
institutional racism which is associated
with
uh helping um the sacred category
because but at the core of this is the
sacralization of these categories
um so yeah that's sort of the the
definition of wokeness and
um you were talking about how
libertarians are useful idiots
right right so so is as that is then
used as a battering ram to institute
policies which violate academic freedom
such as bias response teams such as
um you know diversity training that uses
critical race theories such as
decolonizing the curriculum mandatory
decolonizing of the curriculum in other
words your
reading list must be x percent this and
that x percent that which is
in some places where we're moving which
is a violation of your freedom to set
your own reading list for example
um but essentially you get these
policies that are pushed in institutions
by quite a small group so
what's interesting in the surveys is
only about 10 of academics
uh favor firing uh academics who are
doing controversial research
across a series of different topics on
but that's huge
temperature um one in ten
one in ten but it's also one in ten
amongst non-academics right who are on
the left
so it's not about academics but it is
about
there is a ten percent in in in
population
society you think you know larry elder
was makes the point ten percent of sight
you think elvis is still alive
right and if you send him a letter he'll
get it but i think where you're probably
going eric i'm gonna
guess yeah is that there's a very large
body of people
who while not supporting it will not
vocally oppose it
exactly that's crucial so you've got
about half 40 to 50 percent of academics
who
you know they won't support a campaign
to get rid of somebody but they're also
not opposed to it right and when i say
not opposed i i don't mean they don't
stick their head above the parapet
no i mean even on a survey they wouldn't
be opposed
to firing so that is a
a very permissive atmosphere and and the
further left you are the more permissive
you are on this
and conservatives are obviously much
more likely to actively oppose
so you've got two problems one is you've
got that 10 that are
you know active uh cancels pro cancel
and then you've got that 40 to 50
intermediate group who kind of
sympathize with the aim of you know
protecting disadvantaged groups again
partly because they buy into that woke
substructure of you know these are
sacred groups that are
we have to do everything in our power
because you know so they buy into the
kind of
um progressive aims but they may be a
little uneasy with the
with the the means of you know violating
academic freedom a lot of them have a
commitment to academic freedom
but it's in tension with their sympathy
with
these means and it's interesting you can
change the question around and get
radically different answers
so you might add you if you ask a
question are you in favor of political
correctness
because it protects minority groups or
do you oppose it because it's a threat
to free speech
among social science humanities
academics in britain it's like 75
percent
pro-political correctness 20 against so
massively
in favor of political correctness but
then you ask okay well
social justice or academic freedom which
one do you
if you had to pick and then it swings to
majority going for academic freedom
maybe 55 to 35 against for social
justice
so there's this kind of tension i guess
between these competing values and it
comes out differently depending on
how you phrase the question and yeah
eric let me ask you this because this is
something that i find really interesting
how much of this
is about left versus right or how much
about this is majority versus minority
and here's what i'm getting at
if the majority of the the faculty
at universities were conservatives do
you think
these attitudes would flip or is there
something inherent
about being on the left that makes you
pro-cancel culture or more open to it
and is there something inherent about
being on the right that makes you
sort of like we don't care about
people's feelings we're all about
the research or is it just simply a
function of the fact
like the left is the majority therefore
we want to dominate
and the right is the minority we want to
have some breathing space
how much of that is going on i think
it's mostly what you say that that you
know if it were a conservative majority
then you'd get
the dynamics moving in the opposite
direction that is certainly on political
discrimination
it would be pretty much the same picture
so political discrimination
is heavily down to are you a majority or
are you a minority
but the difference i think is on support
for cancer culture
um and one of the things by the way i
didn't mention was that
amongst younger academics aged 35 and
under
um twice as supportive of canceling
as those 50 and over well that's good
yeah
and graduate students are even more so i
mean i asked four hypothetical questions
and
you know it was about 10 of academics
back cancellation in any one of those
scenarios
but about 25 if you if you consider at
least one people who backed at least one
of the four
cancel scenarios well that number was
over 50
for phd students in the us uh so
one in two phds backs at least one of
these four hypothetical cancel campaigns
so we you know people who say that
somehow
these things come and go you know these
phases come and go mccarthyism came and
went this is going to come and go i mean
really all of the data that we see is
that we've got a more intolerant
generation coming at us and we should
expect to see these problems get worse
and not better
hey constantine do you like success well
i'm working with you so clearly not
there's this great new podcast called
secret leaders where they have honest
conversations
with fascinating people from the world
of business have they taken our strap
line because if they have i'm going to
sue the [ __ ] mothers back
no no no i wrote that bit ah
okay well tell me about secret leaders
then it's brilliant they interviewed
some of the most successful
entrepreneurs in the world my personal
favorite was with huel founder julian
hearn
who explains how to become a food and
drink millionaire
yeah you listen to that one because it's
all about food didn't you yeah
i knew it who else have they interviewed
then i don't know i only listened to the
food once
joking aside though they've talked to
the founders of pioneering startups like
brewdog monzo and joe malone
my favorite episode actually was with
alex stephanie
the ceo of beam who spoke about how
business could solve huge societal
problems
like homelessness oh wow that sounds
great where do i go to listen to secret
leaders
just download it right now from wherever
you get your podcast
all you need to do is search for secret
leaders easy
and why do you think that is eric why do
you think that the young people become
more sensorious than ever isn't that
when you're meant to be more free more
open
you know you want you you know you're
more experimental when you're young
the end of corporal punishment yeah yeah
yeah yeah
no no eric that was a joke you're not
supposed to
that's a latino coming out no you're
that's right um no no um
well god you've i've kind of lost the
thread now what what the hell were you
the question was
why young people oh yeah young people
yeah um yeah this is interesting because
there's other all kinds of other data
that we find you know
there was a survey now by the fire the
foundation for the individual rights in
education
20 000 huge sample um
it's like 75 of people were opposing so
65 75
were opposing having different kinds of
controversial speaker on campus you know
around
someone who's who thinks that all
abortion should be illegal or
someone who thinks that blm is a is a
hate group you know you'd have only 20
25
saying such a person should be allowed
on campus to speak you know yeah
we are seeing definitely more
intolerance why is that happening
i think it comes down to this wokeness
thing which i mentioned which is
if you s if you've been watching movies
and reading books
and in your social media feed are if
you're seeing this narrative
in which um you've kind of got the bad
whites and then you have the good white
allies and you have the
minorities who are kind of and typically
the storyline will be about
you know slavery or it'll be about the
nazis or you know this is sort of
i think a lot of it comes down to
stories and storytelling and the kinds
of
effective attachments people form to uh
certain kinds of minority groups again
those sacralized
race gender sexuality minority groups
that's now kind of second nature i think
to a lot of
uh younger people although i think there
are very interesting divisions within
the younger population which we can get
to later but i think you
you have an acceptance of the sacredness
of these groups now which then shuts
down the tolerance so once you
accept that you can't criticize you must
be ultra-sensitive around
these groups that are sacred because
they have a history of being
marginalized once you accept that logic
then free speech drops down you know so
people say yes
yes to free speech in the abstract but
whenever there's a clash with
um any of the sacred progressive values
free speech drops down so yeah i think
we're facing a growing problem and so i
really think
this is one of the reasons why i think
simply
playing the libertarian long game and
thinking that you know good ideas will
drive out the bad eventually people will
come to their senses
it's just not the case i think you have
to actually enlist government
and public uh sentiment and the law um
to actually start to unpick this in the
major institutions of society so one of
the things i say is we
we can't think of society as just
government and individuals and the
government oppresses individuals and so
we need government off our backs that's
very
1980s reaganite libertarianism that that
might be
the case for the the economy but it is
the wrong model for
what's going on now what we actually
have now is three layers we've got
government
the institutions such as universities
tech firms or
other kinds of charities media lesson
media which is i think
a little bit more free market but i can
talk about that in a minute but and then
you've got individuals
uh and so these institutions in the
middle
are actually where a lot of the threats
to liberty are coming out of
whereas elected government you know they
can enable that
oppression to go on in the middle but if
you're gonna
find a solution to to the oppression
that's happening you actually have to
use
government in the law um and a good
example might be
uh if you think of southern universities
in the us 1960s
they didn't allow black students the
federal government actually had to come
in
and say to these universities you have
to desegregate in order to give
these students their rights so the
government actually had to curb the
autonomy of the institutions
to give autonomy to the individuals and
that's sort of
the situation we're in the government
actually has to lean on
institutions like universities or tech
firms that are monopolistic
in order to free up uh society and
that's very hard for a lot of
traditional libertarians who are just
anti-government to get
um but we have to get past that kind of
1980 style reasoning
and start to use government effectively
to protect
liberty and it's actually not that hard
a concept if you imagine a gang of
people out there who want to lynch you
uh for for hosting trigonometry
i mean there are there's more than one
of them especially in this part of
london
you know thankfully they're very wheat
fish yeah but
but the only way you because the mine
who also has soy milk
listen i have dietary requirements
he's got intolerances of the worst kind
but yeah
so you imagine a gang of people out
there so you need the police to come in
and evict them to to get your freedom
back so you need the state
actually to intervene uh when you have
these intermediate level forces
and and that's the kind of world we're
increasingly living in and and
the problem is not that everyone in
these institutions
is illiberal in fact it's only a
minority who are but
that minority by playing these sacred
values
is able to exert much much more pressure
uh on people's consciences
and and their fear of their reputations
and everything the small group is
allowed to
essentially force multiply itself by
leveraging these taboos and the only way
you get at that
uh is by making it so the institutions
have no wiggle room
so if an institution like a university
sort of is told you're going to be fine
if you abrogate
academic freedom as defined here and
that has to take precedence over any
kind of
uh subjective definitions of emotional
safety and harassment
in your policies then when the activists
come knocking and breathing down their
necks
on twitter in committees and so on
the administrators in the universities
can say well
yes we're with you but we can't do it
our hands are tied and that's
that's the response we're looking for is
to say you know
we don't want the administrators to
declare loyalty necessarily to free
speech what we want them to be able to
do is to say no to
the activists and once the activists are
unable to
to push the administration's in their
direction they've lost their power
and that's the whole point is to use the
law and government to try and take away
the levers of power that connect these
activist campaigns to these institutions
if you can break that link
then all of a sudden you massively
increase the freedom of the people
working in these institutions
and it's not enough to allow people to
sue you know
yes that is important the free speech
union and fire and all of these groups
are doing hugely important work
um and counterweight as well that which
is helen pluck rose's organization
that's usually important that people
actually have some someone to go to if
they come under
attack but it's not really enough
because
still for people actually engage in a
lawsuit that's a lot of money that's
time emotional distress you're just
going to take the easy route
so in order to get rid of rid of that
chilling effect
that says i don't want to touch this
subject because i could be in trouble i
don't want to say this
because i could be in trouble in order
to really address that
you need a proactive government that is
actively looking at hearing
whistleblower complaints that is
acting in real time to shut down
attempts to discipline people whose
ideas
contravene dogma for example um and it's
that proactive application of the law
which is what
what i think we need to move to if we
really want to address the chilling
effects
isn't one of the challenges going to be
so you've used the examples of
university in the 1960s being overtly
racist
but that was very easy to prove very
very very easy to prove
this is far more difficult isn't it eric
um
well it's not hard to prove i mean my my
surveys were which are
by no means the only ones that have been
done show that there is a very
substantial body of people willing to
politically discriminate
so that's fact right yeah um we know
that the universities have become more
and more and more ideologically skewed
losing their viewpoint diversity
again that's established fact uh so
we've got
these two things which are pr now let's
imagine that the university was
had very few black uh or non-white um
academics
in in there or or even students but
let's just take academics
and we had surveys that were showing
that you know 30 or 40 percent of
academics would discriminate again
against a black applicant
you know there's just no way that would
stand nor should it stand
right so that would be sufficient
evidence for radical
change and action to to happen we've got
the evidence
but what the problem and also the
european courts and other courts have
essentially said
you cannot politically discriminate you
can't just fire somebody because they're
a labor party supporter
you know your political beliefs are
protected
so this is not legal um it's not legal
to do it and so
part of the problem is okay how do we
then get to a situation where we can
apply
the law into these institutions and
that's not
being discussed now you don't receive
any guidance that you're not allowed to
discriminate on political grounds
when you're going into a hiring
committee for example the universities
are allowed to be blatantly
political i think they should have to be
politically neutral
at the administrative level not the
academic academics should be able to
have whatever political views and say
them in class well that's fine they've
got their freedom but i think
it's at the departments departments
saying we are a progressive department
and posting political things in their
common rooms
again different if individual academics
post stuff on their doors but for
official parts of the university to be
pushing a political message i think
should not be permitted in
publicly funded institutions like
schools they should have to be neutral
so putting that kind of neutrality in
would i think help to change the
atmosphere
so all i'm saying to you is we've got
the proof i don't think we need more
proof we have pretty strong evidence now
it's just what do you do about it well
this is my my question because what
you're talking about
and i by the way like the the
libertarian position which i used to be
quite sympathetic to clearly doesn't
work in the modern environment there's
no argument about that
you know this idea oh let's just have
another twitter well we saw what
happened to parlour right
right and and it doesn't work it's just
to me that's just a given but what it
sounds like to me
given the the demographic dynamics of
the of a university particularly with
the younger people that you were talking
about
being so woke and so pro-cancer culture
and anand
you're sort of trying to solve a problem
from the top down but the problem is
from the bottom up
isn't that right well that's a very good
question so i think we've got two issues
here and and this is kind of
encapsulated in the sort of chris ruffo
versus idw debate
um you've gone up so for anyone who's
not familiar with it you
yeah so this is really a kind of debate
between
uh chris ruvver who's sort of saying
well you know intellectual dark web
you're
you're you're a talking shop it's great
that you're having these programs but
you're having no effect
on day-to-day operation of people's
lives in institutions and in on politics
now my own view is actually both of
these positions of merit that
you do need to win the war of ideas
ultimately if you lose the war of ideas
even if you get regulation and and the
law
that will only keep the wolf from the
door for so long so you do have to
ultimately win the battle of ideas
to get a free speech culture as greg
lukianov would put it
support for free speech as a cultural
thing in order to
underpin the legal and political
framework however
in the long run we're all dead and in a
way to kind of condemn everybody
to awoke inquisition within these
institutions for the foreseeable future
for at least a couple of generations or
however long it's going to take
right for this generation to pass
through the system and for the next one
to
a more sensible one although i i think
actually this generation is not as lost
as as that might
sound they're actually much more uh
varied and and fractious but still
um i think you've got to play the long
game on the ideas front but you also
have to
uh play the short game which is that
most of the public
are pro-free speech and so you need to
enlist them by the democratic process
to penetrate these institutions and push
them
towards uh you know essentially ensuring
uh
expressive and academic freedom and also
to work on the on the viewpoint
diversity
front where there where that is an issue
as in say the bbc for example or
or as in academia um and i think you
need to do both you've got to fight the
battle of ideas i think
the idw is very important but i also
think what what roofo's doing on
critical race theory is extremely
important as well it's just that rufo is
important for the here and now
um idw's is very important for for the
longer term
although i will say one thing which is
that government policy can shift
cultural norms you know governments
brought in anti-smoking and seat belt
regulations which then shifted cultural
norms around the acceptability of
smoking and not wearing a seat belt and
i think cass sunstein makes this point
in his book on conformity so
it's important to do both and i
certainly don't think government
activity
weakens the energy behind the battle of
ideas as some people
have asserted i think you've got to go
both routes and eric don't you think
the the part of the problem as well is
well let's call it
old-fashioned backbone we see
institutions we had see head of
institutions
capitulating to mobs the latest example
is badly grammar school where the head
uh essentially you know acquiesced to
the mob
and they demanded that this teacher be
fired all the rest of it
and he bowed down isn't that part of the
problem as well
it is but i i'm leery of relying on
sort of strong individuals you know it's
not a sustainable approach people
are going to be rational maximizers
they're going to take whatever decision
is
you know the path of least resistance i
think what we need to do is build
in policies and structures that can make
it easier for such individuals to act in
a different way
um so for example the if the
conservative government
is saying to bentley grammar you know
that was the wrong decision
you either i don't know quite where
where the autonomy lies here but they
might
if for example this was a violation of
the academic freedom of the teacher for
example
um then the the oh you know the
regulator could simply go
to um to the school and say you know
you've got to reverse that decision
and they just have to do it i mean that
would be an example of where
if this was happening a lot and of
course you want to give as much
institutional autonomy as possible that
is the ideal
but where this is then presenting an
opportunity for
uh flash mobs and activists to push on
these levers and they're pushing in the
administrative layer that middle layer
of institutions then the government has
to come in and more or less prescribe
and say no you can't do that you've got
to reverse this decision so that would
be the model
in this case where the government would
or the regulator would say
sorry you've got to actually reverse
that decision simple because
the these are the policies this is the
way um obligation a
sits with regard to obligation b and if
obligation a is legally worded in a way
that says you you know you have a duty
to
as opposed to some other legalistic
wording which suggests that the second
obligation is
like say to safety or something has a
lower standing
than the one trumps the other it's all
about specifying these things
in law i think the free speech union has
some good ideas here you've actually got
to get into the legal
nitty gritty and this is one of the
things about th the whole culture war
thing is you actually have to have a
policy network that gets into the weeds
gets into the way laws are written and
the way these things
are traded off against each other where
the thresholds are
you have to get like with the bbc for
example and i agree with you i don't
agree with defunding the bbc but what i
would agree with
is a more interventionist approach to
for example a fairness doctrine where
you would be able to
look at content and look for balance and
monitor that through which we can do
through things like sentiment analysis
the the the other side needs the sort of
anti-woke side has to get into these
cultural weeds they can't just say
oh we're going to cut this and cut that
i don't think we can cut our way out of
this problem
it's a cultural issue and you need to
sort of engage it as a cultural issue
well you've hinted and teased that there
may be a ray of hope when it comes to
the new generation coming
right so break that down for us a bit
because the the initial figures you gave
us were
really scary half of phds pro council
culture blah blah blah
but you've you've kept injecting little
notes of optimism in there so so
what's the breakdown with young people
what's their attitude well i think it
depends
i think in britain we can see something
slightly different from the us
although we see something that is that
is similar in terms of the way opinion
is shaking up but in britain for example
you know i would say as to put it
crudely 18 year olds are a lot more
sensible than 22 year olds
now um and and you know if you look at
even politically um support for
the labor party for example or corbyn or
whatever
peaks at around age 22 and then it drops
considerably down to age 18.
18 year olds are kind of similar to 40
year olds in this country in terms of
their
political views yeah in many things on
many things and certainly in political
party support left right support so
we're seeing something happening between
age 22 now part of this could just be
they didn't live through brexit that
didn't shape their consciousness and i
think that's
that's sort of my leading hypothesis but
we don't know what is
what is causing this shift to the right
if you like
um amongst the very youngest zoomers
coming in in britain
we don't see anything like that in the
us by the way so i thought there was
some evidence for it but there actually
isn't
sorry guys i'm sorry the american resort
uh but you know because we keep being
told and sort of anecdotally there's
elements of truth to this that
certainly when it comes to comedy which
is our well former field
right you could say before before we we
removed ourselves from it
uh involuntarily but the idea was that
like there's this new generation of
people who like really want edgy comedy
and all of that
coming and you're sort of i mean
possibly hinting that that may be the
case here in britain
it is the case i mean i would say and
this was kind of something i was going
to say at the end of the show but i do
think there's a very
an emerging quite shocking gender
divide on this oh yeah um so
i'm just not sure quite how to approach
that i mean
exactly but i mean it's not to say
that's the most
but uh but you know it's like 30 or 40
points gap in in attitudes
to kind of support for political
correctness
uh some of these attitudes around cancer
culture
between the genders particularly at the
elite institutional level
i'm sorry elite university level so how
is that actually going to
to pan out turns out to be less fair is
that what you're saying
it looks that way but um you know
i think people obviously get married and
then whatever
but but i think um but can we just put
it
in sort of in plain terms women are much
more in favor young women of political
correctness cancer culture et cetera
yes that's right i mean what i would say
is that your your young
zoomer males are not particularly
politically correct
now again this is not to say that gender
is the only thing that matters it
clearly isn't but it's
it's part of what looks to be an
emerging political split this
that's wider than it's been um and and
you see that in the u.s and in britain
now the one thing i would say however is
in our in the 2019
academic freedom report what we saw was
that when we presented a paragraph that
was say pro-academic freedom
people read that before answering a
question like is
free speech more important than
emotional safety you can actually get
undergraduates to shift their opinions
like 15 points
when they read something about the
history of the battle for free speech
but you can also shift them
15 points in the sort of emotional
safety direction when they read about
historically marginalized groups so that
opinion is
is up for grabs in a way that the phd
student opinion
is not and the academic opinion by and
large is not
um so any efforts need to be focused on
the sort of people
before they become adults i mean that is
really where
opinion is more malleable so i still
think there is a lot of hope
that that opinion can be shifted and of
course the free speech union wants the
government to be teaching
about free speech in schools i think
that would be an excellent idea
also students when they come to
universities should receive
just a standard mailing informing them
of their rights their free speech rights
being protected why this is important
that should be standard issue as well so
i think we have to make the case
to younger people because i don't think
it figures in their
thinking very much i mean one of the
things on the fire survey one of the
questions
was actually about allowing someone on
campus who said all whites are racist
now
that's a central tenet to critical race
theory
which is interesting but there only 20
25 percent of students were in favor of
allowing such a person on campus which i
thought was quite ironic given the
emphasis on on uh critical race theory
but
so there is a sort of knee-jerk kind of
intolerance
that is not that is partly ideological
but it's just partly because they
haven't learned about
the importance and the value and the
struggle for
things like the right to criticize the
government in the 18th century in
england you know
even these sorts of things the cultural
revolution in china none of those
stories
they know whereas they know all about
you know civil rights movement and and
the not seasonal which is great
but they don't know anything about the
things orwell talks about
um or or or the battle for the right to
criticize and publish against the
government you know none of that is part
of their
uh education from what i can tell and
that needs to change i think
i love the fact you've been talking
about cancelled content and then it's
right there
oh yes do you have a website
or do you plan to have a website well if
you do
then easy dns are the company for you
easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be council culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easy dns dot
com forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50
off of the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
but on a depressing note eric uh what
will happen do you have
a brand for you yeah it is it's what i
do it's what i'm here to bring
uh what do you think will happen if we
don't implement these changes into
universities
um well i think a lot of essentially
things will just continue
moving in the direction they are which
is that every year
which with every crisis whether it's the
ever art
sarah everard killing or whether it is
the blm
or whatever you get a surge of activism
and
more diversity training more biased
response teams more
decolonizing the curriculum uh
increasingly overt
progressive messaging from the
university i mean you see each time you
get one of these events
the ratchet gets turned up one notch
making things even more hostile
for political minorities than it is now
skewing the truth-seeking mission of the
university more and more away
from what it should be so yeah i just
think things are going to get worse
unless we do something and it's worth
saying that these
some of these changes have been in train
for a long time i mean
speech codes came in in the u.s
universities in the late 80s
so we're now talking about our fourth
decade
of of these sorts of speech restrictions
being in place
so this is not mccarthyism something is
going to blow and then go away
it's not going away unless it's sort of
something's done about it
well uh if you're watching at home make
sure you send this and every other
trigonometry interview to an 18 year old
female
this is how this gets so sounds so
creepy
why there's nothing creepy about it you
know we're just trying to change the
world we're trying to make the world a
better place one interview at a time
uh eric thank you so much for coming
back it's great to have you
i think you're doing important work and
it's really good to get that
information out there and hopefully
people in policy making positions pay
attention as they have done in the past
so with that in mind what is the one
thing that we are still not talking
about that we should be
well i touched upon it and that is
political discrimination you know
should it be acceptable for people in
society to be able to discriminate
uh on people's politics uh whether it be
for hiring
but not just for hiring and firing but
how about socially
um one of the statistics that is
remarkable
in this fire survey is that only seven
percent of
all female students in the fire survey
who did not support donald trump
which is the vast majority right sort of
over 80
only seven percent would date a trump
supporter
now the reverse is nowhere near uh
you know other studies just suggest the
reverse is not as bad as that but
it does raise this question so
right-wing wingmen will happily date
a liberal more so more so yeah much more
so
um but to me that's surprising right
right
but but there is this question about you
know how acceptable should it be
we know that we shouldn't be
discriminating on the basis of race or
invasive religion
but political belief which is in a way a
cousin of religious belief you know
is it acceptable to be discriminating
socially politically on the basis of
political belief
i don't think it is and i think we need
to begin to
really start to go after that and say
it's one thing if someone is an
absolute extremist but just if they are
belonging to this broad category which
may in fact be 50
of your population or you know
brexiteers 52
um actually that's very pathological and
and
is one of the key sources of friction in
society we need to start talking about
that
and perhaps addressing it uh in many
ways
eric when you said that he was talking i
thought you meant like would
liberal men go out of a trump supporting
woman
and the question is that would be
following is how hot is she
right yeah yeah he's talking about women
so it's all very right well it does work
the other way around so a trump
a sort of a someone who who opposes
trump who's male
you know when they're asked if they
would go out with a trump supporting
female it's it's maybe like 20
or 22 percent
and he's only being polite in reality
it's more like 80 percent
but yeah what eric is saying is find
someone you disagree with politically
and have sex with them
that is the recommendation of this
interview consensually
obviously of course well thanks for
adding that now that's creepy
eric it's good to have you back and
thank you so much uh uh for coming on
the show
we look forward to seeing again all the
very best where can people follow you
to keep up to date with what you're
doing and anything they should check out
well you can either follow me on twitter
which is um at e-p-k-a-u-f-m
or you can go to my website www.w.snaps
which is sneps.net
and that sort of lists everything i'm
doing that's actually named
sort of a corruption of of the surname
of a bit of hockey player from vancouver
where i grew up
harold snaps who's sort of a hero of a
lot of people even though he was a
plugger he wasn't actually a big goal
scorer
so why was he why was he a hero he was
just one of these sort of lunch bucket
players who was sort of you know tough
in in games and everyone loved him and
chanted his name um that's the story of
harold snaps really anything like who
can play what does that mean well it
means sort of one of these guys who's
not
particularly flashy but who is sort of
one of these character players who who
in the tough games kind of meets it out
to the other players on the ice
dennis is that like a dennis white is it
just someone who liked fighting
basically
he's not a complete goon but he like he
certainly wouldn't be averse to to
dropping the gloves yeah
that's sounds like the two of us anyway
eric thanks for coming back
uh and thank you for watching we will
see you very soon with another episode
like this one or a live stream
all of them go out 7pm uk time take care
and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below